pretty tell thanks so much for joining
us on the show today there's so much to
talk to you about but the reason that
we're talking today is I've been doing
some more work on the matter of violence
against women and girls it was something
you cared about a lot the same secretary
and it's something that now you're not
in office that maybe you can talk about
a bit more freely what was working what
wasn't working so well and then I'll get
on to daily politics a bit more if I may
towards the end but I wanted to kick
this interview off with talking a bit
about the scale of the problem
1772 women were killed by men in the
year to March 2021 in domestic violence
cases 200
000 cases of sexual assault in the year
to March 2022 which is probably the tip
of the iceberg because many women and
people will not report it seventy
thousand cases of rope recorded and in
May this year the ons revealed one in
two women and one in six months felt
unsafe walking
home in the dark in a quiet street near
their home
harassment assault rape violence even
murder how would you describe it is it a
crisis is it an epidemic how would you
describe the problem that we are
confronting so so Beth thank you for
having me on because these are really
important and significant issues that I
think as a society we have to tackle
head-on we have to confront them and
confront the behaviors and you know the
causes behind them now I think first of
all it's important to say whether it's
domestic abuse or violence against women
and girls it does not discriminate it
affects everyone every gender every race
people from all sorts of backgrounds and
that is why certainly from my time in
government and as home secretari and
Boris Johnson as well as prime minister
you know we were Resolute in terms of
our determination to tackle these issues
and actually almost go backwards to go
forwards to bring forward the
improvements that are required so for
example
when I became Home Secretary the
domestic abuse bill was you know getting
ready to go through Parliament it was
going through key stages and we now have
a Domestic Abuse Act which has gone a
long way and this is important in terms
of providing the support for domestic
abuse victims which you know
predominantly involves women but also
let's not forget children caught up in
that as well providing the safeguards
for them ensuring that they are provided
with homes for example working with
local authorities looking at some of the
domestic homicide reviews that
absolutely have to come with some of the
most devastating crimes such as deaths
and murders and then of course let's not
forget there's been a huge amount of
work we can talk about this a lot more
around policing the CPS getting cases to
court the evidential collection of data
and information case progression all
these types of things well in my view
quite frankly substandard and inadequate
and of course that is what we spent the
last three years working on earlier
today I went to interview Sarah crew
who's the the national lead on this who
you know well enough well with and I
asked her about whether the problem was
getting better or worse and why in terms
of prosecutions of of rape cases why
the country the is so far off sort of
levels in 2016. at a period in my career
we were able to form a specialist team
here in Avon and Somerset and we started
through a series a number of motivated
individuals looking at the problem of
sexual violence we were starting to make
progress on understanding as
practitioners how to tackle it
um for a variety of reasons not least
austerity we had to make some choices in
policing and even in Somerset was no
different from other forces and that
specialism had to retract slightly now
you became Home Secretary obviously in
in 2019 and Sarah there was talking
about Authority that was probably in the
first half of the term of Theresa man to
Boris Johnson but do you recognize that
pretty that because of funding Cuts
because of austerity that police forces
had no option but to scale back I'm the
first to recognizer I mean I've worked
with Sarah I mean she's a remarkable
Leader by the way in policing and the
work that she's doing in this particular
area as a national champion is
phenomenal and we'll talk about aspects
of that but that is the reason why as
Home Secretary I was assiduous in my
determination number one to back the
police but get them the resources that
they needed to do their job because they
are one part of the criminal justice
system and I've always even before
becoming Home Secretary sorry but as a
back bench Member of Parliament I've
spoken about the end-to-end criminal
justice system you cannot have policing
working in isolation of the CPS the
crown prosecution service or the cause
because if you're a victim of crime you
want to ensure that you're getting
Justice or access to Justice and
perpetrators are being brought
um you know to to heed basically so I've
seen this in place and don't forget I've
worked with policemen for over three
years not just on resourcing but also on
skills capability the tools tables for
example but at the same time changes to
laws and legislation and the police
crime sentencing course bill was just
one aspect of that as well where again
very specifically to violence against
women and girls and domestic abuse you
know perpetrators the sentences that
perpetrators so you begin receiving for
serious violence assault would be
increased so when you when you got into
the home office I don't want to dwell
too much on it but if you look at
um police funding yeah it had dropped by
a 60 15 less in real terms between
29 2009 to 10 to 2018 19 when you
arrived and then with the CPS uh MOJ
budget cuts 25 in real terms over that
sort of period so when you got in there
did you see that actually there is not
enough funding we need to get more
resources
number one it's past now sure sure
number one it's a resourcing I've always
been you know I Bang the Drum on
resourcing but the second thing is I I
am very very assiduous about public
financing and funds you know this is how
you integrate the system you know so the
police the police working with the CPS
this is actually about how we integrate
all aspects of our criminal justice
system so it's not just policing in one
corner and the CPS and another corner
it's bringing the teams together which
all credit to Sarah crew and Ava and
Somerset for this particular type of
work on D.A and violence against women
and girls and she's brought the system
together and that is why when now seeing
good positive outcomes in terms of the
violence against women and girls
strategy in December 2020 you've been
home secretary for 18 months now you
opened a call for evidence to hear
directly from the public on tucking
violence against women and girls then
three months later in March 2021 Sarah
everard was abducted we now know by a
serving police officer
and murdered and it triggered this wave
of protest and then you reopened the
call for evidence what happened then and
why did you do that so that was a
shocking period And I I think actually
the whole circumstances as Sarah
everard's disappearance let's not forget
we had covid we were all in that covered
period
um our lives had fundamentally changed
it seemed unheard of that someone a
young girl could go missing you know
actually in front of us all
and I started to ask them really
searching and probing questions around
Sarah's disappearance time it's taken to
get you know information you know all
the all the basic questions around
around her entire disappearance and it
was just absolutely awful
um and at that time of course you know
once we started to hear more about what
had happened to Sarah
I think we should be really honest I
mean the nation's Hearts just sank
um and we all felt broken in terms of
what had happened to her her
disappearance the Killian her murder the
atrocities that went with her and
actually her poor family her poor poor
family as well and it just seemed right
to me to reopen the consultation there
was National outpouring there was
National grief and National outpouring
and actually National you know just just
everything we saw at the time but that
reopening of the consultation I think
did a couple of things number one it
just gave people who had probably never
thought about
given of you know letting their voices
be heard in a public consultation or a
government consultation encourage them
to come forward and Beth we had over a
hundred and eighty thousand people
um reply and respond did that surprise
your shock you or dismay I mean it's it
it didn't it didn't I don't want to say
it dismayed me I looked at it as a
chance to smoke you in the sense that
it's so
commonplace that women are saying we're
being
targeted or harassed I think first of
all it gave them the confidence to come
forward that that was the key thing it
just made me in the sense because it
spoke about if I may say so sort of
wider failure State failure you know
sort of Institutions that you know
perhaps and we know had not listened
enough to those boys so for example
we've heard this in rape cases before as
well not being victim-centric enough you
know this whole culture of disbelief and
quite efficiently well across not just
the police Criminal Justice System right
you know when evidential cases were
coming together the rate review pointed
this out very clearly and the fact that
women I think quite frankly you know
rightly so after what what had happened
to Sarah felt that this could be a
moment of change and like that for me
was a really big rallying moment and I
think was became the Catalyst for the
changes that we've definitely seen since
were you dismayed by the Mets response
at that time you remember the vigil on
clapness oh absolutely the way that was
policed there was a moment where
acidic's career was hanging by I recall
it all you could have actually thrown
her under the bus I recall it all
absolutely well first the whole moment I
remember I was covering it is pretty
Patrol going to call for Cressida Dix to
resign because if she does she's gone so
it was on a Saturday night if I remember
the whole vigil and everything else you
know I brought in the inspector at the
police and inspector to actually look at
everything that had happened and ask
some searching questions and of course
since then Beth let's be very very
honest we've learned so much more about
the Metropolitan Police in terms of
conduct behaviors attitudes and you know
there is now a new chief
chief there mark Rowley who is
overseeing some fundamental reforms and
a plan that he and I agreed part of his
hundred days when he came in but it was
absolutely appalling and also I think
this is important to recognize as well
you know that lack of empathy and heart
and understanding as to what what women
were feeling and I think again it spoke
off this whole feminas culture policing
do we trust the police would we engage
with them and of course those are the
barriers that we've sought to bring the
way that the police that sent a message
to women that we don't
sympathize with your experience and they
were quite heartless about it well I
think that was self-evident Beth I
really do at the time and did you did
you think about asking for Chrissy to do
I was on to her well to be fair it's not
just Cresta it was into it was the
leadership team of the Metropolitan
please why didn't you well would it be
more destabilizing well it's well quite
frankly the live investigations taking
place at the time anyway and the most
appropriate way was actually to call for
the inspector to come in and ask some
proper questions to actually make sure
that you know the bar was risen the
standards standards appropriate standard
do you think that was the beginning of
the end for horiz the match I think I
think it was a range of things to be
honest it wasn't just the one incident
appalling though it was it was a range
of things that we went on to see in
terms of Standards conduct the culture
the whole culture of the Mets misogyny
and obviously that's been subject to
plenty of reports there's a new Chief
now that's obviously a new commissioner
that's overseeing the change that's
required
and you do the consultation and you get
all these hundreds of thousands of
responsive you add in the ones from
before as well
and as a result uh you put 25 million to
safer Street funds you have the five
million safety for women night fund was
it ever enough is that is it ever enough
in terms of what you can do
I think it's it's more than money if I
may say so these funds are really
important safer Street funds I'm a big
champion and advocate of that around the
country they're doing great things to
give women confidence this is the key
thing that they should be free and open
to live their lives go out in the
evenings with their friends Etc that's
really really important and I think that
must absolutely continue I think the
other point about this is It's the
public awareness I think we've changed
attitudes we've raised awareness you
know we want to give people confidence
that they can come forward seek support
but I think importantly but you know I
say this as a mother as a woman as well
we want to live our lives freely and
openly right and not feel the threat of
harassment have you ever experienced on
a personal level
harassment or abuse
you have can you so I as a politician
I've been a member of Parham for 12
years over the last 12 years I've had
consistent levels of I think harassment
and abuse so harassments is just
intimidation
unkind things that obviously said to me
I have people try and follow me home
actually as well so all of that is
unacceptable the abuse much of it's
documented some of it is documented even
in Parliament you know conduct of some
MPS towards one another and myself in
particular people saying that I have no
right to speak out on certain issues
because of the color of my skin because
of my politics for example that's
unacceptable I've had a lot of death
threats cases have gone to court that is
all simply unacceptable does whatever
make you think is it worth being in the
public eye if I'm getting death threats
and being abused like that
it provides pools for thought there's no
doubt about that but I came into
politics I believe in public service I'm
very old-fashioned in that sense Beth I
do believe in public service in terms of
Vince Gates won't grow the rate review
uh they set the rate review in 2021 set
targets to get charge levels back and
prosecution levels back to rates seen in
2016-17 that's in terms of prosecutions
just over 5 000 prosecutions a year do
you think that Target's in reach so I do
so I I absolutely believe it is in reach
and actually you've spoken to even in
Somerset you've seen the integrated work
that's taking place you've seen more
cases go to court but it's in reach for
not just those reasons
um it's in reach because of the support
that's actually going in for women so
you know the independent sexual advisors
the adverse
too long we've seen a lot of Patricia
and you know I used to spend a lot of
time with victims of cryo as a bat bench
MP and you'd see people give up because
of the processes you know long drawn out
processes digital forensics for example
being too intrusive handing over your
mobile phones we've changed that we have
changed that and that is really
important so it is it is Within Reach
and Sarah crew was hopeful it was as
well but
the funding cannot be taken away of
course not of course not the other point
to make as well and is that a message
I'm going to come on to Liz but is that
a message to the government as well
it's in funding so no so so Beth I think
a couple of things here basically we
have been very clear around operation
satira the work that Sarah crew and the
team are doing this this is being rolled
out to other police forces around the
country that has to happen that
absolutely has happened into the fact it
is happening I know it's happening but
also it's that integration across
Criminal Justice System the CPS the
support that goes in from the Grassroots
the community organizations the advers
you know I met them when I last saw
Sarah about six weeks ago these are the
ones that are making a positive impact
and they are the ones who'll hold the
hands of the victims and ensure that
they are supported that money cannot go
and the MOJ are absolutely supporting
that and it's important that we do that
you know when you when you're in
government yes there are plenty of
choices but at the end of the day you
know we have to be on the side of the
victims of crime ensure that we're
supporting them we want to prevent crime
as well obviously but we have to
absolutely ensure that people are
supported lives are devastated through
these awful crimes they really are do
you worry sometimes that some of the
measures that your Administration put in
under Boris Johnson because this is
effectively a new Administration that
they're undermining potentially some of
the work so not seeming you'll talk
about being on the side of victims but
Robert Halford was talking yesterday
about not being on the side of working
people do you worry about that a bit
well look I mean first of all this
government the new government as well
all of us were elected on the 2019
Manifesto and you know my time in
government you know was literally
focused on delivering on Manifesto
commitments it's all about the people
all about the British people you know we
we care about the public I always call
them the people's priorities as did
Boris Johnson as prime minister I
believe in that I absolutely believe in
that that's our duty that's our
responsibility and you know I know I
know my colleagues in government
understand that you didn't run lots of
people thought you might you didn't run
for leadership neither did you come out
in support for either candidate was that
because you didn't much like the look of
either of them well I've always said
that I was I was going to put
literally Party politics to one side
because I had huge responsibilities as
Home Secretary for me the national
security and my constitutional role in
government and I don't want to recount
what happened at the time there's
something it was chaotic over the summer
I think the Public Public saw that I had
a duty to carry on with my job and Beth
you can't be home secretary and then
come out and start joining political
campaigns and things of that nature you
know I've always taken my role seriously
and that was a position that I feel was
right I put I put the interest of the
the country before party quality cabinet
job though I that that for me was not
even a consideration I had the privilege
of serving as Home Secretary and put in
my country first was always a priority
it's been pretty chaotic uh since the
summer as well I have to say you said in
your resignation letter you give Liz
truss your support from the back benches
is she making that hard for you at the
moment well look I've I've said this
she's the leader of our party I was at
conference last week birth and I said
this at conference as well we do have to
come together we've got a Clear Vision
and a clear mandate for the country it's
important that we rally behind that and
just start delivering it let me put it
another way and I won't keep pressing
you but a clear Monday for the country
is she muddy in the waters by
introducing policies not agreed by
cabinet not in the manifesto and that
has spooked the market some of the tax
measures for example do you think that
is much in the water well look I feel I
mean look my message is very clear we
absolutely need to get back to
delivering for the British public and
that is based on the 2019 Manifesto but
at the same time we've got to unite and
deliver for the country you know the
country is experiencing very very hard
and difficult times right now that's his
self confident yes through actions of
the government and it is important that
we put the public first the the winter
is going to be hard there's good work
that's taken place actually on energy
price caps and you know all of those
measures I think it would be useful
actually now to just make sure that we
put the public interest first deliver
for the public and make sure that we are
giving them the support that they need
through Beth what is clearly and
self-evidently going to be on some very
challenging and I'm going to ask you one
thing because other colleagues have said
it and it's that the reversal of the
idea of the corporation tax cut do you
think that would be sensible now given
what's going on in the markets if you
want to put the country fast sure you
need a stable Market there's an irony to
this birth which is Market forces we'll
probably dictate some of these changes
now so you think they'll be bounced I
think I think some of this you know the
market is going to dictate this
primarily because you know we want to
see stability stability is absolutely
crucial for everyone to carry on living
their lives with institutions to
function but actually for the British
people to have this you know the
stability that they need in their lives
as well and by that as well I mean
mortgages interest rates all those
crucial crucial leavers so you think
that they should do it or you just think
they're going to be forced into well
look whether those are discussions
obviously that will take place and I'm
not going to preempt anything but I
genuinely think from what we're seeing
the markets will probably dictate them
okay and my my final question to you you
were home secretary for three years
incredibly busy
insanely busy job and now you kind of
have stopped you're on the back benches
what's next for you do you want to go
back into government do you think you
might seek a career you had a successful
career before this or is your heart
always going to be in politics well look
it was the greatest honor it's the
greatest privilege to be home secretary
there's no doubt about that and toughest
job in government as well famously so
I'm a public yeah no doubt about that no
doubt about that you know you're
responsible for National Security there
are things that I know that many other
people never ever know
um and I was making life and death
decisions on a daily basis alongside
some of the issues that we've been
speaking about but even much wider than
that you know look at the legislation
that I've steered through Parliament the
changes that we made to migration should
be very weird so stop doing it well of
course of course but I am a public
servant first and foremost yes I had a
career previously but I chose to come
into public service and I and I do
believe it may be unfashionable to say
that I believe in serving my country and
that's what I hope to continue to do
okay principal thank you so much for
joining us on the show really appreciate
your time thank you thank you